well The Hollywood Reporter called
Stanley a real-life superhero the 95
year old patriarch of Marvel Comics died
yesterday he was a creator of many of
Marvel's most iconic characters
including spider-man and The Incredible
Hulk Lee Cowan looks at Stanley's
pop-culture legacy from spider-man to
Iron Man The Avengers and the Fantastic
Four that's the world that was in
Stanley's head did you ever worry you
were gonna run out of characters or run
out of superpowers no no that never
really occurred to me it was too much
fun doing them he was the god of the
Marvel Universe he wasn't just some
comic book guy his fans regarded him as
the architect of modern mythology you
know where they say can you take a
picture with New York shake my hand or
something it's a great feeling that
people really care that much it is
graphic artist Jack Kirby and Steve
Ditko brought his ideas to life even
ones that his bosses thought would never
sell and I said gee what if a guy could
stick to walls like an insect that
sounds good so I started trying to think
of some names insect man spider-man
oh that sounds dramatic most of these
seemingly immortal characters also had
very mortal problems which made them
relatable and he didn't shy away from
the issues of the day I mean you took on
war you took on race relations he took
on drug abuse I tried everything that
people were thinking of that I was
thinking of that was concerning people
at the time
are you Tony's stank he had a second
career of sorts making cameos in the
Marvel movies one of the highest
grossing franchises in history
well the 60s were fun but now I'm paying
for it blockbusters however that earned
him very little characters after all
were Marvel's property not his doesn't
make you angry does it frustrate you I
try not to think about it and Lee didn't
just give us characters that fed our
imagination he also taught us that every
once in a while
good can triumph over evil you know I
guess one person can make a difference
CBS this morning we count Hollywood nuff
said
I like that idea that he was an
architect of modern mythology and these
superheroes also had lots of
vulnerabilities sure and good names to
insect man just doesn't have the same
connotation as a Spider Man that's right
and they were all you're exactly right
they were all very complicated and there
are a lot of us whose imaginations
literally were shaped by that man I mean
that's an amazing legacy tactic so many
that's right
think of the Halloween costume exactly